hello everyone and welcome to the first
game we'll be covering from the second
day of the Melt weather Champions
Chester finals it is Arjun Erica AC
versus Magnus Carlsen and this is the
third game of their match first game
ended by Magnus winning it was a very
very hard-fought end game in the end the
Magnus was able to win and in the second
game even though Magnus was winning with
the white pieces Arjun was able to to
trick Magnus and even though Magnus had
two extra Pawns in the end game uh he
could not convert into a full point so
second game ended in a draw and this is
now the third game so Arjun playing
incredibly well but not uh quite dare to
take a a full point from Magnus so maybe
now in the third game with the white
pieces let's see what happens and it is
uh quite an impressive game so Arjun
opens with Ponte D4 we have Knight to F6
by Magnus C4 E6 and now Knight to F3 not
about to test the magnus's name so
Indian defense or Knight F3 they're
going for the names of the anti-nimzo D5
5 and now G3 going for the Catalan
opening D captures on C4 Bishop to G2
and Bishop to B4 with check Bishop to D2
blocking check and now Pawn to A5 just
defending the bishop and if white ever
captures here then you play a capture
some B4 and you have two very impressive
pawns here you have the semi-open a file
for your Rook uh black is very happy
here so instead A3 asking do you want to
go back do you want to capture on D2
Magnus capture so we have captors
captures with the Knight and pawn to B5
now Magnus shows that it is possible to
defend the C4 Pawn but it's very tricky
look at the bishop attacking that Rook
how are you gonna play this Knight's the
E5 for the moment doesn't really do
anything you're just gonna move the Rook
to A6 so instead B3 this is how you
always go after that defended gambited
pawn and this is how uh the only good
way to do it so B3 C capture some B3
Queen captures now again attacking the
B5 pawn and Magnus just defends with C6
it looks incredibly ugly but it is how
you play this so here are John castles
Magnus castles and just The Rook F the
C1 we have Bishop to B7 and now Queen to
B2 now with some ideas of maybe even
bringing the Knight over to C5 or maybe
this Knight is coming to C5 maybe 91
Knight to D3 Knight to C5 all depends on
how Magnus plays this Sonic beat the D7
Knight the E1 and now Pawn to E5 this is
a very very
a tricky move because it gives white a
lot of options do you go uh Knight to D3
do you just continue with your plan to
control the C5 Square do you capture on
C6 because now you can it's attacked
twice and it's not a bad idea for
example Bishop captures Bishop captures
Rook captures then Blacklist Rook V8 and
you've given back the pawn but you have
two to one advantage on the queen side
you will create a pass Pawn at some
point and this is what black plays for
however here we have the characters on
E5 by Arjun and it is now as of move 15
that we have a completely new game uh
Magnus plays Knight captures on E5 it is
possible because arjun's Knight on D2
will also be undefended so Queen
captures an E5 Queen captures on D2 and
now Rook to D1 Arjun says thank you for
the for the open D file Queen to H6 this
is the only Square for magnus's Queen
there are no other squares that you can
put the queen to uh Queen to C7 now goes
after that Bishop in The Rook 8 and B8
we have Knights the D3 again the Knight
is coming to C5 and queen H5 for the
moment Magnus stops this with Bishop to
F3 harassing the queen queen to F5 and
now Rook 8 to C1 gaining control over
that C5 square and there's no way to
stop the knight from coming to C5 so how
does Magnus counter this well as you
always should he plays Pawn to B4
and this is uh it's a pawn sacrifice but
it's a very very complicated one
especially for a rapid game you don't
have all the time in the world to
calculate stuff but I will just show
what happens after captures captures in
Knight captures it seems like uh black
just gives up a pawn but after Rook F to
C8 the position becomes incredibly
interesting yes it's equal material a
but black does have the past C Pawn he
just put a rook behind it and of course
he will try to push let's say queen D6
Knights the E4 now you're gonna try to
get Bishop captures Queen captures of
course white is not interested in this
because if you if you trade the bishop
for Knight then this bishop becomes a
monster once you advance the pawn to C5
so probably Queen D7 uh a queen trade
let's say captures captures and then
after Knight F6 attacks The Rook Rook to
D6 now you get this position and it's
not easy to push the pawn it's now
attacked three times but the problem is
if you ever Advance at the C5
prematurely you can just trade Bishop
captures Rook captures and Road captures
on C5 you can't capture on on B4 because
the Rook is hanging you can't capture on
C5 because mate is hanging on on d8 so
incredibly complicated stuff uh after
this uh B4 uh move if Arjun decides to
to go after a capture some B4 but he
doesn't he just stick with sticks with
his plan Knight the C5 this is in fact
the best um he can do Bishop to A8
saving the bishop and now Queen captures
an A5 this is how he goes for it but now
Magnus misses a very very neat trick uh
he plays B captures on A3 Rook to B5 is
the way to go attacking the queen and
the Knight here and after the queen A7
move which is the only Square to defend
the Knight now you advance the pawn to
B3 and this is how you save your your
pass Pawn if A4 you just move the Rook
uh and the pass Pawn remains on the
board however after Queen captures an A5
B captures and A3 is played Queen
characters and now H6 and now Magnus
just traded down into a basically worse
position uh so E4 uh going after the
queen queen to E5 and now Knight to D3
attacking the queen queen to E6 and now
Pawn to E5 attacking the Knight on F6 uh
yes uh like I said Arjun traded on into
into a better position but now with this
advancement of the Ponte E4 and E5 he
gives back all the advantage as he was
now very very long on time and Magnus
just placed Pawn to C5 now asking uh do
you want to trade Bishop for knight uh
or do you want to capture an A8
capturing an A8 is very interesting
because after Rook captures Queen
captures on C5 you will play Rook F to
C8 attacking the queen and let's say
queen D6 Rook captures on C1 Rook
captures Queen captures on d6e captures
and Rook to d8 uh Arjun would be up a
pawn but it would not be a pawn that
would uh
survive very long so it's basically
trading down into a draw so Arjun as he
is down in the match he tries e captures
on F6 now we have Bishop captures on F3
F captures and G7 and now Rook F to d8
and okay this might be a little bit
better and give a bit more chances the
Arjun to play for the win but this
bishop here is just a monster allowing
this with little time on the clock is
just very very hard to pull off so Rook
the E1 as the roof was attacked you move
the Rook with Tempo The Queen Is Now
attacked Queen to B3 Magnus is alright
let's trade down into an end game Queen
captures on B3 Rook captures on B3 and
now you have this position where Arjun
is for the moment up a pawn and he can
grab another Pawn on C5 he can just play
Knight captures on C5 okay this is not
really an extra Pawn you're gonna lose
that pawn eventually but Knight captures
on C5 at the move you definitely want to
play but the Arjun doesn't play it he
doesn't go for the pawn and C5 he plays
Knight to F4 and this this is a very
very hard for me to understand
uh I I really have no idea why this
Knight to a formula was played why not
capture the past pawn and the Magnus
says all right you didn't capture it he
just plays Rook the C8 puts the Rook
behind the pass pawn and now he wants to
start pushing the past Pawn Arjun plays
H3 Magnus continues pushing Pawn to C4
we have rooked the C2 now and Magnus
again continues pushing upon the C3 with
Pawn to G4 okay now you you created some
room for your king so you can get your
king into the game but now Rook the B2
by Magnus and here we have Rook to C1 uh
Rook C the C1 if you play Rook eat the
C1 to maybe try and go after this
doesn't really matter just captures
captures King will capture and G7 later
on you can play Bishop D1 attack The
Rook Advanced the pawn to C2 and it will
be it will be well either winning or
close to winning for black but here we
have Rook C to C1 and now Magnus
advances the pawn all the way to C2 so
even though even if this was playable
why would you allow this and not capture
that pawn on C5 when you had the option
while upon the C4 is very very hard to
understand here Knights the H5 now okay
you have the G7 Pawn guard and maybe
this was the plan all along maybe Arjun
thought uh the Magnus doesn't really
have anything here I'm gonna if he
allows me to defend my G7 Pawn I'm gonna
have some pressure against him as well
although it's very hard to see how uh
Magnus could now play Rook to d8 but he
goes for Rook seat to B8 which is also
very nice and now King the H2 we have
Rook to B1 and now King to G3 so Arjun
did everything he got the king to G3
denied on H5 guards the G7 Pawn problem
is his position is completely lost now
so feel free to pause the video and win
the game for Magnus well I give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this uh
wild idea and for those of you who just
won't enjoy the show it is of course
Bishop to D1 I already mentioned the
move a few lines ago so probably
remembered it but just in case uh and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show of course we cut off the Rooks
defending each other and now there is
nothing you you can do this Rook is
about to be captured so you have to
capture either The Rook or the bishop or
the pawn nothing really works if you
capture here just the queen gets into
the game if you capture the bishop same
stuff you can either capture or even
play real captures on D1 and then bring
a Queen into the game uh in the game
after Bishop to D1 Arjun tried Rook
captures on C2 he gave up a full Rook uh
but this means that he can just resign
Bishop captures and C2 was played Rook
to E3 and here okay Arjun tried one more
move because it is possible for Magnus
to make a mistake and I believe amongst
all the players Magnus is the one to
make the most mistakes with the mouse he
just uh you know misclicks with the
mouse and then the weird stuff happens
so it is possible for him to play
something like Rook the B7 and then just
get checkmated like this but he didn't
do that after this Rook D3 Magnus just
retreated with the bishop Bishop to G6
was played and he was in this position
on move 41 that Arjun irge resigned to
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here so very nicely played by
Magnus winning game one winning game
three so basically winning both games
with the white pieces and Arjun played
uh the incredible chess in both again
one game two in game three it's just
that uh he he spent a bit more time than
Magnus than he got into time trouble and
then Magnus just crushed him in the end
game every time both in game one and
game two and game three in game two like
I said origin survived but still if if
you put the position to the engine it
will give something like plus eight for
Magnus uh in in several positions so it
was uh well he fought well but now but
not well enough so yeah that's the game
and a little bit of extra info about the
match hope you guys enjoyed that I I
would like to thank Christopher more
Norris mocosoft Mikhail arboy Fernando
Gibson and Harry Barton for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event until it finishes yeah
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day